nous nous trouvons actuellement à goris
une ville de 25000 habitants à la
frontière entre l'arménie et le haut
karabagh à deux heures de route environ
de stepanakert où nous devrions nous
rendre prochainement il y a deux choses
essentielles à retenir de la situation
actuelle sur place la première c'est
qu'un avion du ministère russe des
situations d'urgence avec à son bord une
trentaine de spécialistes et du matériel
médical et militaire a atterri à
l'aéroport de yerevan le contingent va
être envoyé dans le haut-karabagh pour
prêter main forte aux populations qui
reviennent actuellement dans leurs
foyers qu'ils avaient laissée il y a
quelques mois et moscou a fait savoir
qu'elle pourrait envoyer 150
spécialistes supplémentaires ainsi qu'un
hôpital aéroportée aéroportée si la
situation l'exigeait la deuxième c'est
que l'azerbaïdjan a donné à l'armée ni
un report pour le retrait de ses troupes
de la ville de carval chars en arménie
qui devient donc qu el bahdja en
azerbaïdjan en azéri et ce jusqu'au 25
décembre selon bakou c'est par cette
route qui s'étend entre kelbadjar et
goris où nous nous trouvons actuellement
que tout ça chemine transport de
matériel de blessés arrivés et départs
tout passe par cette route qui est un
point essentiel et stratégique et c'est
dans la ville de kelbadjar qu'il y a
quelques jours on pouvait voir des seins
des arméniens préféré brûler leurs
habitations plutôt que de les abandonner
aux azerbaïdjanais voilà pour la partie
la plus importante par ailleurs je
rappelle que les équipes du centre
interministériel de réaction humanitaire
basée à stepanakert sous l'égide de
moscou ont été déployés pour assurer la
sécurité des réfugiés retournant dans le
haut karabagh et depuis le 14 novembre
elles ont escorté par bus via le
corridor de latchine près de 725
personnes
il ya aussi la dimension humaine
culturelle et cultuelle le président
azéri ilham aliyev a assuré à vladimir
poutine que les lieux de culte arménien
serait placé sous surveillance qu'il
serait sauvegardée que les arméniens qui
habite dans le haut-karabagh pourrait
continuer à s'y rendre
dans les faits la situation pour être
pourrait être plus compliquée puisque
c'est qu'on sait que durant les six
semaines de conflit certains sites
cultuels arméniens ont été fortement
endommagées par l'armée azérie nos
équipes ont pu recueillir le témoignage
d'un prêtre orthodoxe recteur dans le
village de dida banques
il est attristé de devoir rétrocéder ses
terres à l'azerbaïdjan écrin pour les
lieux de culte
ball je ne crois pas encore que nous
devions donner des divans cause
azerbaïdjanaise aujourd'hui je vois que
nous devons donner ses terres à une
nation qui n'a pas la conscience de la
valeur et de la sainteté de ses terres
je ressens une énorme douleur et dans
une guerre comme celle ci évidemment
rien n'est jamais tout blanc ou tout
noir chacune des parties a sa propre
vérité à laquelle elle croit dur comme
fer et évidemment côté azerbaïdjanais
les réfugiés d'hier sont heureux de
pouvoir retrouver les terres qu'ils
avaient dû fuir nos équipes basées à bas
coût ont pu recueillir certains de leurs
témoignages
nous avons été contraints de quitter
feeds au lit en octobre 1993 via l'iran
depuis nous nous sommes installés ici
dans le dortoir de l'université
polytechnique
grâce à l'aide du président nous y
retournerons quand ils nous le
permettront nous y retournerons
nous n'avons plus d'endroit où vivre
hafid jolie toutes les maisons sont
détruits moscou et erevan et bakou
semble en tout cas s'être véritablement
mis d'accord sur l'application de ce
cessez-le-feu
les ministres des affaires étrangères
des trois pays ont souligné dans un
dialogue commun l'importance d'établir
une coopération avec le haut
commissariat des nations unies pour les
réfugiés
l'unesco le comité international de la
croix rouge et d'autres organisations
multilatérales afin d'alléger la
situation des civils dans la zone de
conflit et de préserver les sites
religieux et culturels